Noro Donald is reporting from Washington
where people are paying tribute to
President George HW Bush the president's
flag covered casket lies in state under
the soaring Dome of the Capitol Rotunda
and a steady stream of visitors has
passed through since last night one of
the planes it serves as Air Force one
carried the former president and members
of his family from Houston to Joint Base
Andrews near Washington the casket was
then brought to the US Capitol shortly
before sunset a spectacular gorgeous
sunset they say it's almost like mother
nature knew this was a very special
evening a large crowd cellphones in hand
waited to capture this dark moment Nora
is on Capitol Hill with more on this
part of the story nor a good morning to
you hey good morning to you that's right
and I went and visit some of the people
who have been waiting in line all night
to catch a glimpse of the former
president and pay their respects named
what they said but they came here
because this marks the end of an era
because the last president of the
greatest generation was brought here to
Washington for a final time he lay in
state in the US Capitol Rotunda which is
now open 24 hours a day for people to
come and pay their respects in the open
for about 36
and he will continue to Lyon state for
another day before his state funeral
that is tomorrow morning at the National
Cathedral here in Washington
throughout the evening thousands kept
coming including his vice president dan
quayle and defense secretary Dick Cheney
who went on to serve his son as vice
president then President Trump
accompanied by first lady Milania
earlier mr. Trump sent Air Force One
designated as special air mission 41 to
bring President Bush from Houston back
to the city where he served for a
quarter century ultimately in the
highest office his son former president
george w bush waved just as both had so
many times as president back in
washington beneath a watercolor sky his
casket was carried buying pallbearers
into the Capitol it's where he started
his political career a half-century
earlier as a congressman from Texas
inside a military honor guard placed the
last US president to serve in combat on
the same platform which once held the
casket of President Abraham Lincoln
[Music]
and tears filled the eyes of some of the
most loyal members of his inner circle
President Bush personified Grace House
Speaker Paul Ryan recalled mr. Bush was
the first president he campaigned and
voted for the whole experience really
drew me into politics and vice president
Pence remembered a letter his son
received in August when our son made his
first tailhook landing as a Marine
aviator on the USS George Herbert Walker
Bush I took the liberty of writing the
ship's namesake just in time for my
son's winging there came not only a
signed photograph but of course a letter
outside waiting in lines others who had
never heard from the former president
personally said they still felt his
message he served he was a war hero and
he really represents service and he
represents American greatness to me
American greatness that was some of the
words I heard this morning too as I
talked to people who were going in to
pay their respects to former President
George HW Bush you know what they also
mentioned that it was important one in
particular man named David brought his
son Keegan 14 years old to come see the
president lay in state and he said you
know what I wanted to show him that
there are still great men out there and
that public service is a noble calling